Does it make sense?
>> Yeah, and
I appreciate you giving me credit for
thinking of this idea, but
the reality of it is you kind
of forced my hand by not.
I couldn't said right,
right, right, right, right,
down because I don't see
the low level grid positions.
So I don't know if it's 100 or
1,000 or 60 or anything, but cool,
I mean that gives me credit for
something that I don't really deserve.
>> Well, but I did tell you that
you could go up, down, left,
right if you'd said well,
I'd tell you to go right,
I just would move right a little bit.
And you would have seen where I was,
and you would have,
I gotta keeping going right,
keep going right, keep going right.
And yeah, I could have made that
as granular as I wanted to,
but it has to be fairly granular.
There's no way to get from here
through one of the doorways,
which you absolutely have to do.
So let's be a little bit more concrete.
So let's write down exactly
what that action was.
I don't know what it is, but you created
a bunch of actions that I'm going to
say are things like goto doorway.
And we can even name those doorways.
Let's call therm x.
And so that would be one, two,
three, four more actions,
which are going to allow me to
save possibly many, many steps.
So let's think about that.
What if I had started here?
What would you have told me?
>> Well, in principle, the plan
that I gave you could still work.
Just go to the doorway to the east and
then go to the doorway to the south.
>> Right, and by the way,
well, go ahead.
>> Well, it seems like the room layout
that you have makes it possible to go
kind of the southerly route as well.
>> Right,
there's some point where going east and
then south is not as good as
going south and then east.
And I don't know exactly where that
point is, but I'll make it easy for
you by drawing a dot there.
[LAUGH] What would you
tell me to do there?
>> I would totally tell you
to go east and then south.
>> Right.
>> So east to the doorway,
south to the doorway, then down.
>> Right, so for a whole bunch of states
inside of this room, no matter what I
do, the action is the same,
even though I'm in different states.
I should still just go here.
I take one action for
one particular state.
So the plan itself and sort of what I'm
searching over is actually much simpler,
and that would be true for, I think,
probably any space inside of this room.
Your answer would be?
>> To go to the south door.
>> Right, and not to drive the point
home too much, but what about from here?
Well, I think it's obvious,
you tell me to go here, from here,
you tell me to go here.
At some point, there's a switch off
between whether going through this
door or going through this
door is the right thing to do.
But there you go.
And then once you're in the room,
well then,
you're going to have to take, I guess
sort of baby steps towards the goal.
But regardless, I'm going to claim that
this is an easier kind of space to
reason over than having to live
in the original action space.